but you too I mean there's no but you
can work for three years on a project
and not absolutely love making a film
oops would do that yeah no you know it's
it's just that stubbornness that
determination where you know you start
something you want to see it through you
know and this project this project was
really difficult to make you know this
one you know we should we started with
nothing you know like you know literally
you know Gregor and I were going back
and forth in terms of what the idea is
you know I forgive me I can't remember
the exact see to it but but essentially
you know what happens we had the idea
you know a guy in actors going to be is
in his last week in LA before he leaves
to go home and so you know I knew I
wanted to sort of start him on you know
the first thing we shot was him hiking
and I wanted him to sit down and talk to
God I wanted to sort of him to talk to
God before he begins to talk to the
people in his life before he leaves so
that was the scene we're going to shoot
so it you know the the the place that we
shots not too far from here we had we
had our little canon hv30 and it was
myself Karen and Gregor and we had this
we didn't even have like true sound for
it so we had like this microphone that I
plugged in like was this crappy little
microphone that like really is for a
tape recorder and I plug that into the
camera and you know I know about as a
filmmaker but I was just using what we
had you know and we went out we went out
to the wash out here and and we just
started filming the scene and karen was
like sort of like the boom mics he was
like kind of holding the camera and
during the shoot like the microphone
fell apart and broke we could use it
anymore and we did we just you know we
just kept shooting anyway you know and
then that was sort of the beginning of
that and you know I said I said I've
said before like during screenings like
really you know big part of making this
film was just like just just moving
forward and it was sort of like a Chan
going train wreck that you just try to
like try to you know I don't know how
stop the hemorrhage if stop members
eager just three just it's just it's
just a train run loose and you're just
trying to like guide along as best you
can and that this thing was incredibly
difficult
and once we got into post-production
things just have getting more and more
complicated so but you know I mean look
there's there's some great i just want
to share this before we go on to
whatever or whatever happens look
there's some number one there's two
three actors ah by the way we were
stunned Ida had no idea that you were in
the film I we were like and we actually
wrote names down we were like oh my god
uh I don't know what you did I don't
know I don't know if you worked with
them I have no idea cuz we have no idea
how you filmed it uh but we love the
performances we thought that was one of
the strongest thing of the whole movie
completely believable people yeah we
really because that's one of our biggest
gripe with independent bells yes you
know the whole look shocked oh really
that's that your shocked face and uh so
they love that in and I don't want to
give anyone but uh we loved the ending
we just loved it because that's what you
get with independent films i'm not i
think you know we just saw a six month
rule with blind by blaine and i'm giving
anything away at all but one of the
ballsiest best endings and that's what I
love about independent that is what I
love that we get to do yeah so you get
to do things that uh if we were going a
different route we wouldn't be allowed
to do and I I really appreciate that
night we SAT and watched it in fact we
both said I think we know exactly how
this is going to end and we didn't so
that was a huge compliment because
normal we know exactly what's going to
happen and uh but I mean I mean what I
you know I get this sense like I do you
feel defeated I mean or do you feel are
you tired I'm tired well yeah I don't
worry I've been working on the website
all day and Dave's been doing a lot of
the stuff with the with the release so
yeah I mean there's a part of me that
that is tired and I'm just trying to
just move through but yeah I mean I'm
Oh cable to be asked this then look here
you make you can cut this out but this
is really what interests me about
talking other filmmakers let's keep it
keep it good and here's what i really
want to sit and talk about filmmakers
not about how it the film was made and
all that kind of stuff how do you all
get through the day I mean it's gotta be
tough I mean because we sit here and go
are other filmmakers going to this same
thing we're going through every day like
is it a stroke but some wards were like
Christ yeah we got got to update the
website we got you know we've got like a
hundred things on this Twitter we got to
thank these people these people were
nice enough and it's not a disdain port
but it's just and then we and then we go
through this both of us one of us will
undoubtedly say this are we just wasting
our time like what are we doing here you
know the person has to be the coach and
God forbid we're both in that same level
that day you know so I always I'm more
fascinated by that like what do you all
what how do you all handle it especially
as a couple I mean that's a really great
point one is the coach and one is the
patient and it can take it can be
reverse rolled for me when late at night
like I'm not really that much of a night
person so around like midnight I get
that way and that's when I turn off the
computer and go to bed but and I feel
better in the morning but then there are
mornings where it's just like I just
can't do this right now like I just
can't you know and and and then and then
it reverses and so I think it's this
weird thing that when one person is down
the other Khanna is up and yeah I got
four be at the time when you're both
like that cuz it's just no good and and
hopefully it's just like one would like
this contrarian mindset that's going to
go exactly the opposite of the other one
so I I think sometimes just getting out
of the house helps me because we're
behind our computer so much and and I'm
okay yeah and Twitter it just drives you
nuts like I have to turn off tweetdeck
in the last few months I've been on
Twitter way less and it's just I have to
turn it off sometimes and walk away and
then I'll come back to it and then you
feel fresh again but you
to kind of sometimes walk away I think
you're better it's sitting in and no hi
tom is telling me you're eight it's
sitting and editing and all that and yes
yeah it's definitely a grind you know
and we're in a position where it's even
I like sort of that burden like the
heavy burden is even heavier because
we've been at this for over three years
you know we've been grinding it out like
really it's been intense for the last
three years you know Toronto because as
we started film kurz the radio show at
that st. like a couple weeks or a couple
months in we started filming goodbye
promise so we know we just figured cool
will get you to make movies will do this
radio show thing and and then all of a
sudden like like film car is just keeps
kind of like taking on its own life and
and and so that's just getting bigger
and bigger and then all of a sudden for
me it's like I'm not really spending
that much time making the movie and so
there's all that conflict that comes
from that and it's look we go through
the same thing I mean you know in and
it's you know it's just it's a struggle
it takes the toll on the relationship
because we have to you know there's I
think what you said is truth is you got
to get away from this and at the same
time I think I'm I don't know how you
are at this I'll get away from it for an
hour I'll leave and I'll start feeling
guilty like oh you know I mean
Christ like and it's just it's mine
screw that um you know its knit we don't
get to just make the movie and worry
about making the movie it's it's it is a
24-7 thing that is because we've been
we've been since isolation what is this
six years six seven years that I think
what what kills us the most is we've
spent six or seven years and we haven't
been able to show anybody ain't it we
have a minute you know are isolating
that's your family my parents are like
yeah you're doing a movie yeah cuz we're
no longer
isolation because our consultant wants
us to wait until I have to crawl
crawl and put it out because he's like
you'll be able to sell that to certain
parts of your audience so you know we
feel like we get that every day now one
of its like are we wasting our time uh
you know the same thing Karen and and
while I understand other filmmakers
sending you their scripts I go ha ha why
am I gonna read your hundred and pump it
I've got I got Twitter to do I got an
update instagram i've gotta do pinterest
I've got and I'm like it's it's crazy it
is literally an insane way of life and
sometimes I have no idea how we make it
through it and still talk to each other
because it just becomes but I'm the same
as you like I have to get away and and
the fact that we live somewhere
currently that's like in the middle of
nowhere the closest thing is walmart and
i was like i never thought there'd be a
day where i was excited about a trip to
walmart i feel like i'm going to walmart
today and we need coffee creamer yes
really excited to get out like Kenneth
said yeah it's a it's a it's a it's the
things that nobody ever writes about
there's nothing romantic about sitting
in front of the computer screen for 10
hours on time retweeting and thinking
and yeah it's it's uh we constantly go
what are we doing and we're like what
we're filmmakers and we're like what
we're not filmmakers were social media
hounds like that's what we do I you know
I did say that's why I say literally the
test audience I think kind of saved my
belief in what I'm doing because that
made it all worth it for me because
everything else then went away and I was
like if I could have that feeling once a
year I I could I could stomach doing
this if I don't have that feeling I
don't know I can do this for another 20
years yeah
and given its oh it's really tough yeah
no I you know there's no question we're
in the same boat okay mean you know what
I mean that that comes up you know not
just once a day I mean there comes up on
time they'll all be of all that's coming
across like what what the hell are you
doing Mike you know is any of this work
anything and that's also part of the
reasoning in terms of at least for me
like I feel like I have to do something
like I can't I can't just sit in this
face and that that's where sort of just
like this leap of faith and in terms of
me you know yes I'm exhausted yes I'm
tired yes I'm getting less sleep but I'm
not necessarily depressed right now I
feel energized you know and that's what
I wanted to do to myself that I wanted
to give myself that that that purpose
you know yeah I think it's so important
to have that purpose and you sort of
touched on the test screening for you
for me um you know like I've gone from
making so many little short films and
then you know I've made night before the
wedding which was the film before this
one and I made this one and sort of the
path for me has been like you know you
finish the film and you send it off to
like lift these little review sites and
and you get you get the feedback and you
get it all excited when you get these
great write-ups about your work or
whatever and and that's what I've been
my path and then you know I figured it
would be similar with goodbye promise
you know what kind of do the same thing
get out to these these bloggers and
review sites and have them review it
because of the work that Karen and I did
for two years hosting screenings in la
at the downtown independent we had a
relationship there you know and we
decided we want to screen the film there
for two nights we were just going to do
one thursday and another thursday
because we felt like that's all we're
going to be able to do is we're all
going to be able to get like 400 people
to come out and see the film I don't
know if we can do more of that here in
LA and as we approach the owner Jim
cursed he said you know what Dave I
really I really want you to do a full
week run and then you know maybe you've
got a chance at the LA Times and some
other you know some other press and and
and to be honest the deal for the week
run was actually a better financial deal
than it would have been for the two
nights so it's kind of like I
guess we have to do the theatrical run
we knew we probably wouldn't fill the
seats at all but it's just like if you
have a chance of some big press it's
like you're going to take that path so
we went with the theatrical run and at
the very last minute we're like Jenna
where is this LA Times then fall and
then finally like he gets it to us under
the wire and we have to be somewhere and
we get the email like that like one
o'clock or something we got to be
somewhere at three and he's like this
DVD the screener needs to arrive
overnight it needs to be there by noon
tomorrow otherwise it's a no deal so so
we sort of race we get that we get the
screen already we get it in the mail we
should we make it to where we have to be
and then on the car ride I mean it costs
$18 to overnight I'm driving I'm waiting
for him in the post office like okay we
gotta go we got it and then we finally
yeah and it's just like did I just waste
$18 yeah it's just like it's just like
what am i doing like you know like no
one's seen the film yet like no one has
seen the film yet and I'm setting our
film to the LA Times to be reviewed and
it's just like and i just spent eighteen
dollars to do it and they're gonna look
at this film and they're gonna totally
bash it and I'm like I already know I
didn't think that first I thought like
there's no way they're going to review
it there's no way they're gonna talk
about this film so I'm like you know I
just I just wasted 18 bucks and then I
start thinking like you know what if
they do review it they're gonna totally
batch it you know so you know then that
then that review comes in and and and
it's this glowing review and it just
kind of like really from really from
that point forward it's just like really
nothing else I don't need any other
validation so it's like no matter it's
like no matter what happens no matter if
sums because what's happened is we've
had a couple of smaller critics review
the film since and if they haven't given
it those glowing reviews you know so if
I had gone that same route and gone to
those same people as I had done in the
past I wouldn't have this this feeling
of just like validation and satisfaction
it's like now it's like it doesn't
matter I you know it's like no matter
what anyone says I have I have the LA
Times behind me and it feels it feels
really good I'm just gonna say and we
didn't even think anything of it we were
just like we sent it out there we
thought it probably won't even get
reviewed and I think you found out about
on Twitter you were on the phone and and
and some tweet came in and and so I mean
it just it was just weird how all that
happened and not even sure what my point
was but it just yeah you got to just put
it out there i guess i guess that's the
lesson well i mean the things got on
fascinating about that which is probably
good for us to hear is that it's just as
crazy for everybody else's as it is for
us because I mean just this scenario
that you're talking about where all of a
sudden you're running around like I'm
Ian that's the line screw to me of this
whole thing you run around like a
lunatic trying to meet some deadlines
and you go why what is this gonna matter
like what we've done this 20 times and
nothing ever but you just you got to
take every chance and again what you
just said you gotta tweet about this
like that and again so that's why we do
all the work that's why we force
ourselves on there every day because
look I can't deny our one of our saviors
has been peter broderick and you know
how I found out about him because I put
a tweet out that I was needing to find
someone that was really experienced Ted
hope saw it said I suggest peter
broderick use my name and we got to sit
meet peter broderick and i go so while I
sit here and I laughs and it's very good
therapeutically for us to hear that
we're not the only ones that go work
like crazy and can't stand it but we
love it and it's just the daily
challenge the truth is these little
payoffs start to build up you know and
it's just these that could only be there
because of everything that we're doing
you know still it's difficult I mean
yeah difficult for you than me I I wake
up every morning it I get my cup of
coffee and I go shine their Facebook
they're okay I'm all up oh let's start
here and I just go yeah it's it's it's
crazy yeah yeah that's crazy it is yeah
yeah and on our side too
very difficult to manage you know the
amount of requests that were getting I
mean the soul there's so many emails is
you know there's so many things
happening on Twitter on Facebook and you
know we're trying to manage our time as
best we can at the same time we're
trying we're trying to do the things it
takes to finish the film we're doing the
things it takes this decided you know to
have it completed get it ready for
release and it just just all this stuff
you know and then and have him have a
life on top of it so it's if you all
okay so because I was helping my ass off
about this because somebody was having a
hard time one day and I was like I was
like I made the mistake I I said look I
you know when we first met we talked
about and I told you this has been my
path because i had done isolation on my
own and I knew what it was going to take
to go through this again and I was like
look I'm just telling you you walked are
dating mean business but this is my life
this is what I do and she was like I'll
never forget it what are you kidding
this is so exciting this is making a
movie and I was like okay and so I
brought that back up she's like yeah
look let me tell you right now if I
would have known all this I'm item added
different answer back then but I go do
you remember why you started this all in
the beginning like I have to go back to
that sometimes and go I remember going
this is what I want to do and why like
can you remember when you guys were like
we're gonna we want to be in the film
business I remember the day we had the
conversation about the radio show I
remember that day the film business I
don't know because it's just always been
a part of when I met you you were always
wanting to do that and I had been
on-again off-again about acting and then
I get a regular day job and give it up
and all that and so but now I think film
courage has just really taken over our
lives and really I'm more about that
right now I think yeah did anything yeah
you know and for me it started I started
with you know my story goes way back to
sort of like my last year in college you
know where I sort of had this idea of
like making a movie I don't know where
it came from i just kind of had this
idea of a
I just want to sort of write this the
story idea and you know so I recruited
some of my friends to sort of write the
screenplay with me you know that that
turned into this ambition of coming to
LA to make this movie though the four of
us and we ended up making the journey
and then that thing really didn't pan
out at all I kind of kind of fizzled and
yet here we are in LA and so I had to go
backwards and really start figuring out
like structure and storytelling and that
sort of thing after a couple of years of
that it was like okay um you know what
do you have to show for I don't have
anything to show for it so then I
started getting into like trying to just
do a couple you know a few improv short
films and it really has just been a
progression of one thing or another you
know I just I can't remember at this
point in time like what that initial
seed was in terms of making movies it
just like it was just this dream this
goal as I was finishing college like
what am I gonna do in my life and that
that really it was something deep within
me you know certainly didn't think it
would lead us this far and I'm this sort
of wide-ranging path all right you know
and then really as we got ready to
promote our first film you know we
started that you know I started
recognize like you know what no one's
going to care about this film we don't
have any kind of audience you know you
know we had done we had done an
interview as guests on an la talk radio
show we saw cool that studio was and I
saw that you know because what happened
was our film has a porn started the
first one at the time for a wedding it's
a bachelor party movie and the porn star
was supposed to do the radio interview
with us she ended up not being able to
make it and Karen came along for the
ride just just to be a part of the
experience and I really wanted to order
more tests boy was going now you getting
to build you're getting the real shocker
you get the real stuff so is that four
star good job so Karen shown up like one
okay all right I'm going with you keep
going
a bad back ever since mom sorry okay oh
no no so we did this we did the beach
ended up in the studio and we and we did
we did that interview together you know
she got to talk about the film and she
got to talk about her life and and we
got back in the car we drove home and
for me I could just see the excitement
on her face you know and she's like I
really love that experience of doing
doing that that interview and and so you
know some of other things happened after
that and a long way we just said you
know what let's let's start our own
radio show or we can kind of do it the
way we want to do it because we because
what you know as we continue to try to
gather press I mean I guess the reason
why I felt courage started is because as
we were looking around and saying like
okay how do we make people aware of our
film the kind of outlets the kind of
outlets that we wanted at that time we
couldn't find you know and when i typed
in like film podcast or independent film
podcasts there was nothing I'm like I'm
like what is going on like why doesn't
the kind of Content that I want to have
out there you know that's sort of like
this gateway to independence and why
doesn't that exist so so I guess that
became an inciting seed or something and
so as we started to think of like what
we want to do with our show like that
was sort of that that was the whole idea
behind it and and I and as we did that
then that sort of took on a life of its
own you know we you know that's it so
that's its own story there do you all
still love it yeah I think there's parts
but we really love yeah we love hearing
people's stories we love like reaching
out to some filmmaker and and seeing if
they'd be excited to come on or write an
article or whatever it is and then them
saying yes and like that new contact
it's almost like closing a sale or
something in some way to us and so I
like that and I like finding out about
you know unusual films and stories and
stuff I think the part that gets hard is
all the stuff that you feel obligated to
do the social media and it's a necessary
evil you have to and the emails it gets
a lot I mean it's just
it's a lot you know and so I think just
feeling like and if you don't get back
to someone in time then you feel bad and
I like to be able to always get back to
people and I can always enough I've let
my Twitter go like I don't even follow
people back now and I feel bad but I
just it's just it was out of control for
a while and I had followed a bunch of
people and then it was stuck and so just
dealing with like that whole social
medias up and now there's tumblr there's
pinterest there's I mean it's just like
Google+ I mean oh and it's never going
to end yeah you can you realize it it's
just there's always going to be new
platforms there's always yeah it's a
yeah it is insane I mean I think in gave
up on a couple platforms you just were
like I'm not doing it yeah I struggle
weekly with two items gonna delete it
everything just forget it like I'm so
done with social media and I'm like okay
can't do that but yeah sometimes I just
have to just not do it for a while cuz i
just get to is too overwhelming
sometimes because you you know what I
hate about it is is that you it becomes
such a job that you forget the great
things that happen you know you guys
gave us probably the biggest jump start
that we ever had when you guys were nice
enough to put us on your show because we
literally are followers doubled ah and
then we met David online I'm you peter
broderick online we met Jesse we met you
know uh Gavin I mean there's a bunch of
people to admit that when there's no way
we would have ever met without social
media it's just they're just reaches a
point to where you go okay these people
we've never spoken to before our entire
lives and they've sent us five messages
to retweet their thing and we go well
I'm you know they're a filmmaker and
they're trying to make it but and and
you know you just get a wave of it and
you're like I'm still trying to make a
movie here and I'm still trying to come
trailer we're trying get a poster
together I'm trying to get followers I'm
trying to cover this campaign and you
just like good Lords I see you got it I
mean the internet brings out the crazy
and some people yeah it's just knowing
that
just like who are oh you're insane but
you know what needs to happen is see we
need to come over with a bottle of one
in place rates and then and then the
next morning everything is fine then I
can go back to social media it's the
going to bed at twelve o'clock at night
turning social media off waking up six
hours later and turning it social media
right back on and you literally we can
lose a week we can be like what day is
is yeah yeah damn Oh Friday comes along
I'm like come on lucky I kept it then I
can't even sit what am I gonna do I'm
like why the ASP already yes thank you
yo yo oh god I looked at personnel files
like cost but I don't even what to do
here I give up on this I I would kill
that person by ever Mendez gotta be
shooting themselves that's not how they
intended it was supposed to be you pick
one person that week that you were
inspired by her for whatever reason and
give a follow Friday shout out to that
one person he's tweeted about it he was
like I never intended for it to become
this insane like every person you're
following follow that person but just
turn into that sea nut but if I were to
do that I would get email I know I get
him up tonight this you all why are you
not why you didn't I'd be like huh
that's why I just I just thank people
who do to me now yeah I do the same
thing yeah and it's not that I mean to
leave anybody out and it's just it's
become so overwhelming yeah I mean
that's not the same thing that's like
the very weird dark side of social media
you know where it's like all of a sudden
you don't send someone back a follow
Friday and then you know you start
wondering like are we so cool or like
what's going on its like if you just
take away the social media everything
will be perfect like you know you
wouldn't have these thoughts at all but
because we're so connected it's just
like you start wondering like what the
hell do we do like why is it this person
talking to us or whatever it is that's
right I'm Jersey already right yeah yeah
do you remember it's you know what it's
like do you remember the myspace days
when everybody used to that's not the
top friends like wait a minute I'm
number two on their top friends now I'm
number nine what did I piss you wait a
minute send them an email did we miss
them all or god forbid you weren't on
their top friends anymore yeah it's it's
uh it's crazy the way it's all worked
out I mean it just is but you know uh
you know here's the thing i'm going to
say i had this very interesting
conversation about social media and film
i had this with David actually I I won't
make it last more than a minute but I
think there's actually something to look
at here well I've been on social media
since my space and working it hard every
day so five six six years easily and now
I've spent all this time and let's say
collectively I put all those people
together all the platforms all my
friends and let's say there's 40,000
with them all together and I'll put
something out and I make it 10 or 15
retweets or sometimes 30 likes
collectively which is fine that doesn't
bother me now here's the thing and this
has really intrigued me I spent five or
six years gathering up this shoot this
audience I literally and I've had never
had a magazine contact me I've never had
anybody contact me over all that work
about a project on mon nobody's ever
contacted me on that um I put out a
press release with my teaser trailer for
pictures and a paragraph and we had 20
articles written about us within five
days now I go does that mean this social
media because they didn't they didn't
they didn't go to my platforms and go
well they're only on facebook or they
only have a hundred friends and so I go
in a sense is it a waste of time
because I got more reaction at is
sending these press releases to these
magazines and these established you know
fangoria bloody disgusting and all that
i sent them a professional press release
and within five days every single one of
them wrote about me we had more hit
counts on the our teaser trailer than
any other video we've ever put up and I
go and at the same time I have been
trying for day after day and day and day
and day and I can never get more than
five people 10 people a day to react to
something up put on social media so I do
wonder sometimes is it really working
well it comes it's a collection you know
it's a collection oh you know it's you
know number one is you know the phone
thing that we often fall into or at
least you know we fall into and we see
is that it doesn't it doesn't start with
social media you know like that's not
where you go first you know and and and
unfortunately part of building and
audiences you're going to start engaging
with people I guess you have to start
somewhere you know so you might not have
the product yet but you have to start
engaging with people yeah but in terms
of the way in terms of the way it's all
going to work the way it's all going to
come together is is when you know you
had you have a little bit of that
audience but really you're leading with
the product first you know that's right
an answer you know your engine you
didn't run ahead and you have that that
high level kickass product that people
are like oh my god this is incredible
like right when you come to the floor
with that and and then and then you
begin utilizing social you know social
media then it's really gonna come
together you know when you're seeing
that right you know when you're seeing
it all spark you know when you're seeing
like all the press releases and all that
stuff kind of happened you know I
believe certainly you know cuz you know
carica speak on this as well when we're
hit up by a lot of filmmakers and stuff
we will take a look in terms of you know
what how
they stand into what's their stature on
facebook on Twitter right now like
because you just get a sense in terms of
like do people care about this are these
people that get behind their own work
you know because there's a lot of people
out there that are just looking for the
waiting to be discovered I you know that
they're not putting in there not rolling
up their sleeves and not putting in that
work you know and I believe you know so
it's a requirement but you're not going
to really see it come together and so
until the work is really out there and
you're leading with the work you know
that's a good point because I mean yeah
it's a very good point because the
reason all these magazines jumped on us
is because we gave them the content you
know I sent them the trailer I sent them
the photographs I sent them the article
and versus me just sending them what I'm
gonna do you know uh so yeah that's a
good point it's a good point but I think
I think I think what really drove home
for me is you realize that it is a
balancing act you know you you it's not
the end-all and Beall sometimes we kill
ourselves and try and become you know we
try to get 15 new people following us we
try to get this and I go you know what
just kind of let that happen put your
work in let that grow but once the
product comes out that will kind of take
care of itself I don't think you can
ignore it ah but you're right we didn't
have a product you know that's what we
spent years doing you know building us
up to 1,600 followers what you're
touching on there now that's what I was
going to touch on it is really for like
the last year you know I already you
know we're not we're not necessary
monitoring the followers as much when I
we're not monitoring that the facebook
likes as much it's just like we're at a
point now where you know we feel like
we've got it up to a comfortable level
you know where as you know it gets
competitive you know it's just like you
know you just you just want to like you
see other people have like five thousand
lights on facebook it's just like like
you know what are they doing with the
magic and it's like but it's just like
you know what over the last year at
least for me I can't totally speak for
care for me it's just like I don't care
about anymore that like that's off the
table you know because we've gotten
ourselves to a point where that that
doesn't matter anymore and for me it's
just like we want we want to put out the
very best content we can and if people
are going to follow us if they're going
to like us it's not going to be because
of like we have so many followers or
likes it's going to be because the
content is so compelling that they just
have to follow they have to be a part of
it there's been a major shift there so
we continue to engage with people on
Twitter on Facebook but at least for me
I don't care about the numbers anymore
i'm done caring about the numbers and i
gotta say this because this is just as
is so fired up over clout okay i'm so
tired of out cloud is a manufactured
competition and I actually told i remove
myself from cloud because I should get
any tweets from people or your cloud
scores only like thirty one mine 70 ana
ma what the hell out is like a waste of
my time well you know it you know what
that is to me it's it's it's again the
same thing you're talking about which is
we all get caught up I guess that's what
I was trying to say you know I mean we
me personally I don't know about
everybody you know you get caught up in
thinking that your value is the social
media platforms you know how am i doing
over here on Twitter well how many
people do we have on facebook well okay
well now nobody's liking our stuff on
Facebook so you jump out and it's kind
of like it really is a mind screwed it's
because and I guess that was my point I
went holy Christ these when we send out
when we said I literally thought we
might have three people write articles
about a teaser trailer and I realized
it's because people aren't putting
content out the majority of people are
on there they'll make a poster they'll
retweet they're going to do something
and I just it's it really is insanity in
one respect I really do believe it is
insanity I mean we just literally all we
do is just I could see our fans are
gonna have a heart attack with we've got
do we got that feed on tweetdeck and we
just scroll through it going nowhere
okay wait what is bed and then we go all
right retweet that ok then you go and
I've got my mentions come over here and
I'm like I don't even know who that is
and you know what no no and I just go my
god sit what's was Stanley Cooper doing
this like what was him and I go no no he
was running around making movies and
making these things that nobody saw
about these crazy little five-minute
films he was showing on the side of
buildings and I was like are we just
rude like what is going on but I don't
know i think it's finding that balance
and I i I'd be the first one to say I
don't think we have found the balance
yet because it's still dry NSA it is a
cause of turmoil here at least once
every three or four days on but from one
of us like oh my god okay please you've
gotta handle that this more I can't look
at this anymore and uh yeah it's just
it's insanity but for some reason I
guess that's what I can't get an answer
to of why we feel it's so important and
i go i don't know i think it's that
stupid thing like i know an instagram if
you post a picture and it gets like over
a certain amount of likes it's like oh I
got 20 likes and you feels good for some
stupid reason like that's gonna do
anything for you in the large scheme of
things but you're just like right
because I don't know if this is
happening you all but this even happened
today I swear I put up a cruel
crawl image and it got like thirty nine
lights and I was like yes and I was like
all right um can we afford coffee cream
this week what 10 yeah the world didn't
change those Lions Gate didn't call no
but he's like wow you are somebody now
and I'm like how did I get caught up and
giving us whether somebody likes it
five times or 32 times and they don't
find myself looking at somebody trickle
isn't even an artist nikka 552 likes and
I'm like how's this son of a 952
likes and I go it's it's yeah I oh it's
crazy it literally is crazy I think I
can't imagine what its gonna be like in
15 years I literally I I just my dream
this will sound horrible should I say my
dream is to be able to fund my movies
and just delete every account except for
one and they just go you all can go on
there and say what if you want I'm not
thou coming everyone so long ago Merry
Christmas like like like ya told you not
only one that feels that way believe me
yeah we focus a lot of people that was
share those same feelings you know yeah
um yeah it'd be nice to be that point
you know it's it's like it's like it's
just it's just part of hustle terms
we're at you know yeah I personally
believe that you know you have to build
up a certain level of influence so that
as you begin to spread your message you
know look because you for me always like
kind of you like you have to kind of get
your butt yourself above the noise or
above the clouds so that as you begin to
sort of spread your message you'll have
like quicker access to the people that
really matter you know and if you're not
above the noise it's like you're so far
down that it just it just takes longer
and it takes more effort to just kind of
get your message out in that quick and
easy manner so no that's a point I
wanted to bring up before I forget
because this is probably something that
was on more on topic than what I took us
on sorry about that but uh you know
that's that's one thing that you were
saying you know because we are
interacting socially and because things
take so long that has become one of the
biggest challenges as filmmakers for us
which is okay let's say we go six months
and get in the film festival
okay then we're still lookin another
four or five months before it's open to
the public because whatever deal with
strike whether we strike a deal whether
we have to do something else so we're
looking probably at another eight to 12
months before it can be sold as a DVD on
online and everything and I go how do
you sustain fans to be interested in a
project that long you know you can't put
out five teaser trailers you know so
it's it's become a pacing thing for us
because we know I mean I literally get
people that are angry they want that
trailer and you know our distribution
consultant is like no you're not putting
that trailer out until you're in a film
festival and in about two weeks before
that and so we go wow we're going to
keep our fans how we're going to grow
how we're going to keep momentum going
and we go we're not you know I you
there's that there's nothing to do so I
think that's something I learned from
David Baker I gotta give them credit on
this which was I know next time now that
we know this we are going to
legitimately spend four or five days
filming a whole pre story to whatever
story we're going to tell so that we can
put out little two minute videos online
so they for so for gaps like this
something can be being shared instead of
hey go like our Facebook page because
how many how many ways can you say that
sorry yeah no no no he just feel a
little cat craziness over here um yeah
you know I what can i say i mean we're
you know we're in a position where you
know we're creating so much content like
this that we do through film courage so
you know I we're just do you guys have
your air conditioner all yeah yeah so as
I made where's that here going man
Christ plan is no smell hasn't here how
hot is it there today
like 103 oh yeah okay yeah that's
similar yeah I saw similar to eat here
yeah so you know this is you know how
prepared you guys have any more
questions for us by chance ah well I
mean I do have a couple questions real
quick i'll make them real quick for you
one ah now that you've done this do you
do you feel as a filmmaking crew there
that you need a break or are you fired
up to start on the next thing like where
are you guys at emotionally on man I
think I'll just start in there I think
creatively we want to do something but
for so long we're not doing creative
stuff we've been doing the tweeting that
the emails all that and it's not like
it's not my forte you know I'd rather do
something creative so I think that's for
me why not yeah I mean for me it's been
it's been such a burden on my shoulders
um you know mainly because film kurz did
become its own animal and trying to make
a film at the same time I mean it's
never taken me three years to complete
like a film for so it's really that that
becomes really difficult you know
because you know you're essentially like
as you begin to promote and put
something out there you know you're
making a promise to your audience like
you said you know you're spending your
you're making a promise like we're gonna
finish this and we're going to give you
a chance to see it so the fact that this
is sort of taking so long and obviously
when you crowdfund that just adds to
that burden so for last few years you
know I've never I've really had this
like just heavy weight on my shoulders
and and you touched on it earlier oh you
know in terms of you know you really
can't do anything right now until crawl
crawl is really out there you just
you trying to feel this weight and
that's exactly how I felt for the last
couple years it's like um you know we
have our first film is available on
Amazon this one we finally our life
releasing it's like yes I mean I've to
jotted down a lot of different ideas of
things that i would love to develop and
go make but for now i'm content doing
with
Karen I deal with film courage and agree
me I just haven't been able to commit
any time whatsoever so it's a really
flashing on idea that you know that I
really want to go make another film
until until release this film until like
it's all the way done then maybe I'll be
able to sort of take a take a step back
breathe a little bit and then see what's
there because this is scary for me
because this is like you know I mean we
shot we shot the film three years ago
when we kind of done pickups along the
way but there wasn't a script for this
film so I haven't really written a
script now since going back to two
thousand eight and so it's like you have
to find that creative energy energy
within you know and I've been sort of in
marketing distribution promotion mode
for one cooker for a long time now and
it's just like I'm kind of like scared
after we come to the end of this push am
I going to be able to like turn back
within and have that story there that
I'm gonna like feel that deep passion
for of like let's go on let let's do
this all over again that's what is like
let's do it all over again so that
that's kind of where I'm at right now um
you know and so you know and I'm sure
saying for you it's like you have so
many ideas so many stories that you do
want to tell and and sort of the draw to
those ideas kinda they kind of come and
go you know it's just like one bite it's
just like that one idea like just the
ideas won't stop coming to you and then
and there may be a couple weeks later
changes and there's like this other idea
you've been stink around your head and
so there's like that they give and take
that that's that's happening there and
meanwhile I'm just like no no I'm like
I'm like no stay up stay out i got i
gotta like i gotta get this film then i
gotta put it out there I have to stay
committed you know you don't want to get
too distracted oh and I look how I look
at it look at how many little side
projects she and I started during this
whole process I mean you know i was
doing this little web series i did three
oz like what the hell my daughter she
did some i did some you know just
anything to fill up the time creatively
and but you know it's one thing i always
feel is good for artists to share with
other artists so that they don't ever
think they're alone look we went to that
same exact conversation of what you just
said
you know Nicole who is said to me I
remember we were sitting here and she
was like uh you know are we sent off our
film the peter broderick to see what he
thought of it and what he thought we
might be able to do it that we were
waiting and I was like look you know
prepare yourself you know just if he
comes back and doesn't like it doesn't
mean we're going to stop and it probably
wasn't the right words for me to say at
that moment cuz it literally looked like
all the blood drained out of her and she
just said there and so I was like you
okay like i don't i don't know that i
can go through that whole process again
and just have nothing happen you know
and it was that moment that every artist
goes through i've gone through it you
know it's it's uh it's tough but i think
that's a natural thing i think that once
you do a project and you get out there
the reason you do another project is
there was something that you didn't
capture you know but for me i always
need a little bit of downtime and to
re-energize and cuz you're still in a
fight I mean you're still your goal is
to get it out there to as many people as
possible let's tell I mean it's hard
there was stressful ease ya know we've
spent you know we've spent already 12 16
hour day whatever it is I don't have an
hours but we spent you know we're a few
days in now so we're like you know three
four days into our campaign right now
it's taking that much energy with
everything we've already done previous I
mean we just went over a hundred dollars
or offering our film for one dollars so
I know in the internet it's the craziest
thing I literally when we were doing our
our hardcore ND thing we would watch
people going hey I'm it I'm a Jimmy
James restaurant and all that and we're
like it can't give us a dollar like that
we're offering a dollar buying and they
just wrote me and said they don't a god
but there are chains eating and you just
yeah it's you know it's what do we say
we'd wake up in the morning and go k put
the monkey
Sudan you can have the symbols all right
here we go let's go to work and it's uh
yeah yeah you know it's tough but again
I really enjoyed your film uh I'm really
excited to see how this works and I
honestly cool I hope it blows out of the
water because I would name what an
interesting concept Emma if you guys if
the film community and the fans get
behind what you're doing that's a
platform that's a platform that other
filmmakers could go well I don't have to
go on netflix I'm going to go going up
if I've got my audience there and I can
make I've made my film for a hundred
bucks and I can make 25,000 on it that's
profit I can take that and go start
another one so I really i have high
hopes for I really did thank you know we
do too you know it even though I'm
describing the the hustle that it takes
just to get a hundred people to pay a
dollar you know in this case I mean our
average donation right now our average
contribution is seven dollars so that
that's pretty wild the fact that right
you know we've had over a hundred people
now contribute in the at you know we've
had two people give hundred dollar
donations that's pretty well it's pretty
well all you're offering is an online
rental of your film but there's someone
who's you know there's a couple people
that are so passionate about the film
they believe in it so strongly and on
top of that they believe in sort of this
this this this path that we're taking
with the film that they're like you know
what I want to I want to just get by
it's not it's not even the money it's
just it's really just a statement of
just how strongly they feel about it
what they're just going to say like just
do it just go for it so for me that was
really touching you know it was very
touchable to kind of hit those kind of
contributions I think I lost my trainer
and also some of the emails to that
we've gotten from people just about how
it ties into their own journey so when
you see that it's like okay wow it's
like what you guys talked about watching
it in the audience or with the audience
and high seeing them high-five each
other with our film
we've had some people that maybe have
been you know it's been more sad in some
sense but they've come to sort of a
realization in their life so I think
when we get emails like that or comments
that's really that's like okay wow this
was all worth it yeah and honestly I'm
not I'm not depressed them I know I'm
tired I'm going to be tired too tall
stretch but I'm after I really feel
energized I feel great I you know we
knew going into it that this was going
to be a ton of work to get these to get
these early people to buy this film you
know at the same time we didn't want to
just give it away for free you know you
know tonight the value of getting people
to actually you know an actual
transaction you know that's what you
want you want to just just have you know
you want to sort of create that because
that's you know part of that is like is
like training a lifestyle or another
lifestyle but just you know you want to
create as an artist you know you want to
offer the work we didn't want it we
didn't want to offer free we just want
to offer to people and just kind of and
let the whole thing work its magic a
little bit you know and I guess I'm
thing I was going to touch on was um you
know we wanted to make it we just wanted
to make it super easy not not just not
just for the audience but for us you
know and really I don't know that you
know dish you know not that we're like
the press they're like oh you know it's
just it's just it's just really
frustrating because there's no guarantee
you can get on you know I itunes you
need an aggregator and like there's no
clear path just just to get it on that
platform you know and so that's kind of
frustrating I guess I guess though the
one where it's like the least resistance
I guess would be amazon you know so if
you want to just go right the amazon
sort of work that that one has the least
resistance it doesn't ously have like
the best payout for the artist and of
course you're gonna have to put a lot of
work in on that platform but that would
be another way to go but even netflix
that had you know that that's like an
easy way to get it to the audience it
doesn't that favorable deals for the
producers at our level and it's not it's
like it's only it's getting tougher and
tougher to get there it's like you know
believe me if we could just take our
little film and just get it on all those
platforms we'd be off and running on
with it but there's a lot of the factors
that go into it in terms of all the
deliverables that go with it on the cost
of delivery
and and you know in this sense all we
needed was our project file and we use
IndieGoGo as the storefront we use that
with YouTube and it's just like it it
can't be an easier for us like that
there's nothing easier on our end and
it's just like BAM now we're off and
running and that's what we wanted you
know so yeah guys billion I mean I you
all have actually given me an idea for a
short film that I want to do that I was
like the ribs and I didn't want to do it
is I was like look you know there's no
pipe I can't put this on iTunes nobody's
going to give a damn about this short
film on itunes and awe like I said but I
went you know what he's done is
brilliant and that's where I could put a
short film on and you know it's gonna
cost me maybe four or five hundred
dollars to do it I was like I might be
able to recoup that for five hundred
dollars maybe maybe and I was like I
like what you've done big and locate
you've given another filmmaker hope for
a project that I literally was like I'm
not going to take my time to do this
short because I'm not gonna take it to a
festival gee I never understood that I
know people do it love it and that's
great and thumbs up to him I just uh I
don't have the money to go put it in
Film Festival and go I know I'm not
gonna making money on this and I want to
spend money one in there Bubba block but
um but I went that's a brilliant idea
IndieGoGo because even if I got forty
dollars i'd be like a bouquet we got
four guys I'm going to have pizza and
and forty people watch the film you know
it's in it's not just up on YouTube by
itself I think what you're doing is
really really fascinating I really
really hope it works all right really
really truly do and and I can send it
selfishly because I I hope because I go
that gives me and it should give other
filmmakers and a WoW moment of like
maybe we could do something like that
and use it the same way and maybe make
some money so we can pay the electric
bill and people are looking at the
project and it's creating an audience
and you we don't have to get forty
percent of it amazon if they'll even
look at it yeah it's just
I think it's I think it's brilliant idea
did you go on I do a real quick question
i'll let you all go because you can turn
the air conditioner on the sick cat by
the way i'm sorry i kept to leave photo
class completely fine we have 14 cats so
do we but we have treats every morning
um is there uh did you work did
IndieGoGo like did you have to tell them
that this was a fundraising project or
like did you just tell them hey we're
going to use you as a rental service
like how how did you approach them you
know we approached IndieGoGo you know we
approached Slava dinnae and Adam chap
niqab chap nick is the CEO of distribute
he's also one of the he's like the chief
person in terms of film on IndieGoGo and
I was able to get into a conversation
with with you know I mean Slama got back
to us and said hey since this is a film
project why don't you talk to Adam so
you know I I pitched the idea to add him
a little bit on the phone and he thought
was a very intriguing and interesting
idea and and and I asked them I said has
anyone else tried this on IndieGoGo and
so that there's a whole there's a whole
story there but by said but essentially
with any go go you can put up any
project you want really you know like
you know it yeah if you but if you look
at it you know they basically welcome
any project like any idea you have that
that you want to you want to put up
there ok that's where you're seeing like
the the bus monitor sort of that sort of
thing explode you know be people putting
money up this is set to Center on a
vacation you're seeing like people from
from the colorado shooting and and you
know these recent shootings victims of
those shootings that people are just
putting up projects for the families all
right so so there doesn't seem to be any
restrictions or limitations on that
right now unlike starter has i guess
that's what i'm making out there yeah
yeah so honestly as as we've been
looking at it we just saw sort of like
this sort of loophole you know you know
yeah just all like this thing it's just
like its own like I I
if you would like the DSLR cameras and I
like all of a sudden we got these
cameras that are given us this amazing
visual images and you're able to change
lens and do things like that it's like
waiting it this isn't just so this isn't
just a photo camera or a picture camera
like this is also you know a video
camera and then you know I'm being
modified everything like that and as i
was looking at itunes and i'm looking at
amazon and all this stuff it's just like
all these platforms are just so boring
like you know it's just like we've
gotten to a place right now where
crowdfund anything is so exciting it's
just like you know raising money for the
project is more exciting than actually
like releasing the film when it's done
and I'm just like you know I'm like I'm
like what's going on here you know like
what do we have to do they get the
excitement in the release not not in the
funding but like when the film's
actually done if people can see it and
right that's where I'm just looking at
IndieGoGo and I'm just like you know
looking at crowdfunding and that sort of
thing so I had all those factors going
for it and I didn't just see a
crowdfunding platform what I started to
see was a distribution platform yeah
it's brilliant I do i do I love it yeah
alright well look it was nice all day
long here I don't we are too I'm like
I'm like I'm getting right I see I've
got my controller right here guys have
I'm gonna be like today would thank you
guys you know I know we haven't really
asked you yeah this was really cool yeah
I think sometimes we'll cut out but it
was just nice to hear from you guys that
same thing like you know is this all
worth it and you know just driving all
this time and you get this little who is
that we were talking to the needle moves
just a little bit described by Gregory
bein that wasn't yeah the needle and end
and just moving that needle a little bit
more no just pushing at you out a little
bit further yeah and we are hopefully
there's one or two film festivals there
in LA hopefully we can go to and even if
not we're gonna have a screening there
after of our premiere and we'll have to
hook up I mean my god we gotta we gotta
get together for dinner that'd be fine
yeah I know that that's always going to
say is you know unfortunately I mean as
you guys were filming screening and
filming crawl no we really wanted to be
there no that goes it was in our hearts
like man it'd be so cool to just hang in
there you know CSEA please you're not
hardly working uncle go to work what's
that well we dreamed about having a film
bird show here what like on set while we
were filming we thought that would be so
awesome but again those are things to
wear when we have money and time and
said something out yeah yeah yeah but so
but this this conversation was great so
I was going to say that you know this
sort of served that purpose to some
degree to kind of you know we don't have
yahoo that we don't have any food in
front of us but this was like sitting
down I was goddess and good luck okay
thank you guys for taking time off we
enjoyed your film very much we're
looking forward to sharing arms with you
ya know it works out to see it works out
of the seat see y'all later